[Musique]
tout le monde le sait le chien et le
meilleur ami de l'homme le meilleur ami
du militaire aussi
[Musique]
au sein de nos armées on dénonce plus de
2000 chiens employés pour la recherche
ou pour l'intervention ce sont des
compagnons hors norme des soldats à part
entière sur qui reposent parfois la
réussite d'une mission
[Musique]
nous sommes à Budel au Pays-Bas dans ce
chenil une quarantaine de chiens ont été
triés sur le volet pour tenter
d’intégrer les armées françaises selon
un cahier des charges très exigeant
assez courageux pour faire le test
suffisamment mieux pour comprendre ce
que nous recherchons un chien intrépide
et qui s'est mordre
aujourd'hui l'agent recruteur c'est
l'adjudant Gwendoline 19 ans de service
elle appartient au 132e régiment
d'infanterie cinotechnique qui est
notamment chargé de la sélection des
chiens au profit des trois armées durant
deux jours elle va soumettre ses chiens
à des tests extrêmement poussés dans un
premier temps on a fait une phase de jeu
sociabilité
ensuite l'indifférence au coup de feu
ben forcément on a un métier d'armes on
sera amené nous à tirer des coups de feu
avec nos chiens aux pieds dans des
phases de travail et si le chien il a
peur des coups de feu il sera
inutilisable
ensuite la phase de courage et là ben
c'est pareil on va proscrire tout ce qui
est crainte et agressivité incontrôlée
et enfin la qualité de mordant bah
forcément vu que c'est des chiens qui
sont amenés à faire du mordant et du
travail d'interpellation et ben il faut
qu'on soit sûr que cette qualité là
la scène et spectaculaire pourtant le
bâton est creux plus impressionnant
qu'il n'y paraît
l'adjudant Gwendoline recherche des
chiens d'intervention le critère
déterminant la puissance de leur
mâchoire
la sous-officier ne se laisse pas
attendreir à la moindre erreur
l'aventure s'arrête pour ses chiens
finalement Gwendoline va retenir 18
essentiellement des malinois qui ont
entre 10 mois et 2 ans parmi eux ce
chien a tapé dans l'oeil de l'acheteuse
son nom Rocky c'est un chien qui est
très sociable qui est super abordable
qui dans le travail est super demandeur
et en plus de ça il est joli et en plus
de ça il mord très bien
pour Rocky il doit maintenant prendre la
route pour rejoindre son affectation
provisoire
4 heures plus tard arrivé à Sud dans la
Marne au sein du plus grand chenil
d'Europe
pour commencer l'animal est mis en
quarantaine afin d'éviter toute
propagation de maladies à partir de
lundi les chiens vont sortir tous les
jours pour faire du jeu du bâtiment du
milieu du mordant des coups de feu afin
de les préparer au mieux pour les pour
la livraison aux différentes armées mais
avant cela Rocky va devoir passer entre
les mains des vétérinaires l'équipe
soignante doit déterminer s'il est a
remplir sa mission pour lui rien n'est
encore gagné
donc on fait un premier examen de fond
d'oeil je vérifie qui est pas d'atteinte
de des structures profondes de l'oeil
pendant cette visite d'incorporation
rien n'est laissé au hasard chaque
partie du corps est minutieusement
ausculté
donc ça veut dire que derrière il peut y
avoir une disposition une pour les forts
voilà je vous laisse y aller merci
les radios permettent de détecter
d'éventuelles dissimétries au niveau des
hanches et des coudes cause d'arthrose
prématurée chez le chien une pathologie
éliminatoire ça fait boiter donc
au niveau militaire qui a un emploi
relativement physique ça peut pas le
faire
le parcours du combattant est terminé il
fait désormais partie des chiens d'élite
de l'armée française
d'ici quelques semaines il intégrera une
unité de l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
sa carrière devrait durer 6 ans
comme beaucoup de chiens militaires ils
suivra son maître en opération à des
milliers de kilomètres de la France ces
missions difficiles nécessiteront un
suivi vétérinaire régulier
tous les ans il a une visite
systématique annuelle et c'est également
à ce moment-là que évalué la petite
opérationnel du chien c'est la capacité
qui va avoir à être projeté en opération
extérieur sans avoir de problème
sanitaires et après sur un animal blessé
militaire en théâtre d'opération
extérieure généralement il est pris en
compte de la même manière qu'un
combattant et il va avoir une évacuation
sanitaire qui va être faite la seule
différence c'est que son maître
normalement va l'accompagner et va
rentrer avec lui puisque il faut le
gérer
un juste retour au vu de la longue
histoire qui lit l'homme au chien très
tôt il s'est révélé être un allié
précieux il s'agit de la première espèce
domestiquée et ce avant même la
naissance de l'agriculture
les premières traces de domestication du
chien par l'homme sont maintenant très
anciennes c'est au tour de 35000 ans ça
fait déjà un laps de temps
très long et donc un compagnonnage très
long entre les humains et les chiens
alors la grande guerre c'est une grande
période d'invention de l'utilisation des
chiens parce qu'on va s'apercevoir que
ce sont des auxiliaires extrêmement
importants
alors durant la première guerre on a
commencé par les chiens sanitaires
c'est-à-dire qu'on l'aura appris à
reconnaître les uniformes français à
prendre le képi à l'emmener vers son
infirmier pour lui faire comprendre
qu'il avait trouvé un blessé et ainsi à
le ramener ensuite vers le blessé avec
la guerre des tranchées les choses ont
complètement changé dès la fin 14 début
15 ce sont les français qu'en ont eu
l'idée dans les Vosges d'utiliser des
chiens pour guetter l'arrivée des
adversaires et puis ensuite l'autre
utilisation qui était très importante ça
a été de transporter du matériel des
munitions dans les premières lignes dans
les tranchées et enfin la dernière
grande fonction celle vraiment qui est
devenue la fonction à succès à partir de
1915 1916 c'est le chien messager le
rôle lucien est plus restreint au cours
de la seconde guerre mondiale pour mieux
le protéger
le chien obtient de plus en plus un
statut tout à fait privilégié et ça
devient difficile d'en faire une chair à
canon et la diminution de l'utilisation
du chien et due à des moyens
technologiques nouveaux mais du surtout
à ça si le chien est tellement prisé par
les militaires c'est notamment en raison
de ses formidables qualités naturelles
les chiens ont des capacités et que nous
n'avons pas ou en moindre degré par
exemple la capacité olfactive elle est
bien plus développée chez le chien
jusqu'à un million de fois supérieur à
la nôtre ils sont capables de repérer
les odeurs anciennes
les odeurs récentes et les odeurs qui
arrivent autrement dit un chien on
pourrait dire qu'il vit dans quatre
dimensions y compris le temps
une conviction profonde pour les
militaires un bon chien et d’abord un
chien heureux on a compris depuis une
trentaine d'années que
l'efficacité d'un animal est totalement
liée à son bien-être on s'est rendu
compte pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale elle a la deuxième guerre
mondiale qu'une bonne utilisation du
chien
suppose une très bonne entente entre le
chien et le conducteur et c'est
maintenant une idée qui est extrêmement
importante dans les armées modernes un
chien ne peut pas être un bon chien s'il
n'y a pas vraiment un lien très fort
avec le conducteur
les fusillés marins de Cherbourg et leur
chien peau qui cédrat et Naxi vivent
cette osmose au quotidien le chien fait
partie de l'équipage au même titre que
les marins humains
ce sont des marins des marins à quatre
pattes ils ont un matricule comme
n'importe quel personnel militaire ils
font l'objet d'une sélection d'un
entraînement comme n'importe quel
opérateur le fusil marin opère dans un
espace terrestre mais également maritime
et son compagnon à quatre pattes doit
pouvoir le suivre dans toutes
circonstances
et hop
pour ces chiens une obligation avoir le
pied marin
c'est une des meilleures nageuses de
charbon donc faut savoir que donc les
malinois sont des chiens très rustiques
ils sont beaucoup plus résistants à la
chaleur et au froid que d'autres animaux
et que nous ils ont un sous-poil en fait
qu'il est protège vu que nous dans la
marine on est amené à intervenir donc
sur des bateaux et sur des zodiacs en
engagement si jamais on se retrouve au
même titre que l'homme a tombé à l'eau
avec le chien il faut pas que le chien
devienne un boulet ou un point mort et
qui risque d'accentuer un risque de
noyade pour son propre maître
l'émission de ces équipiers sont
multiples les chiens d'intervention
assurent la défense des bases et des
ports de la Marine nationale
suivi
national
quant au chien de recherche ils sont
dédiés à la détection de matière
explosive ou de stupéfiants l'intérêt du
chien dans la lutte contre le
narcotrafic c'est sa capacité à évoluer
dans des espaces restreints de manière
beaucoup plus efficace qu'un opérateur
humain c'est également sa capacité à
sentir de même il a une meilleure vision
nocturne qui lui permet d'opérer
notamment dans les bâtiments ou la
marchandise peut être cachée des fois
dans des endroits très exiguës il a une
vraie plus belle
en tant que si nos techniciens nous
sommes déployés à bord des bâtiments de
la Marine nationale au sein d'une équipe
de défense et d'interdictions maritime
dans les océans indiens et au niveau des
Antilles pourquoi opérer sur ce genre de
lieu c'est parce que c'est une plaque
tournante pour la drogue les résultats
sont impressionnants au large du Golfe
de Guinée dans l'océan Indien aux
Antilles et en Polynésie française en
seulement 6 mois de janvier à juin 2021
la Marine nationale a saisi près de 32
tonnes de drogue
par ses qualités exceptionnelles le
chien peut aussi sauver des vies la
Brigade de Sapeurs-Pompiers de Paris a
elle aussi recours au chien dolphe
action spécialisé dans la recherche et
le sauvetage de personnes en ce volume
le sergent-chef Sébastien avec une de
ses situations dramatiques
le 12 janvier 2019 une fuite de gaz
provoque une explosion dans une
boulangerie du 9e arrondissement de
Paris ce jour-là j'étais en position de
repos et il y a le chef de groupe
pilotechnique qui m'informe que une
équipe est partie sur un renforce court
renforce court chez nous c'est quand on
a des collègues qui sont mal en point ou
qui sont pris dans un ancelissement dans
une explosion ou qui sont blessés et il
me dit prépare-toi parce qu'on va
sûrement partir renforcer l'équipe de
garde il m'appelle 5 minutes après il me
dit bon bah rentre vite à la caserne
arriver rue de Trévise au cœur de la
capitale c'est une vision d'horreur le
souffle a tout dévasté dans un rayon de
100 mètres on savait que c'était fuite
de gaz mais ça faisait plus penser à
soit un attentat ou soit une image de
catastrophe ça m'a fait penser à un peu
l'ouragan Irma avec des voitures
retourner des vitrines cassées des
vitres partout il y avait encore une
personne un de nos collègues ensevelie
donc forcément les recherches doivent
être rapidement menées et on doit être
actif sur ce genre d'intervention
avec Ithaque son berger bel Tervueren
Sébastien prend par aux recherches si
binôme se relèveront au cours de
l'intervention on est arrivé environ à 9
heures après les premières équipes si je
me rappelle bien et on est restés jusque
au moins minuit 1h du matin parce que
forcément oui elle est reconnaissance
rapide à faire pour retrouver les
personnes qui manquent mais il faut
aussi couvrir tout le secteur parce que
ça avait aussi impacté les immeubles d'à
côté et il fallait aussi faire tous ces
toutes ces reconnaissances et tous ces
relevés avec les chiens pour ne pas
oublier d'éventuelles victimes malgré
l'importante mobilisation des secours le
bilan est lourd quatre personnes
décédées dont deux pompiers plus de 60
blessés et 400 sinistrés des missions
physiquement et moralement difficiles
qui demandent des chiens aguerris à
l'aise partout peu importe ce qu'il se
passe
on les entraîne quotidiennement dès
qu'on est de garde et dans un premier
temps on leur apprend à Boyer ensuite à
franchir des obstacles on rajoute du
bruit des gens mouvements sur le terrain
des odeurs différentes on met des
personnes détenues différentes on fait
intervenir des camions avec les
gyrophares tournants des fois dans les
caches on met des personnes retenu de
pompier parce que comme on l'a pu le
voir sur le trévis bah ça peut arriver
ce soir un de ses entraînements a lieu
en banlieue parisienne sur une aire de
formation cinotechnique
les pompiers vont devoir faire leurs
preuves dans ce mille-feuille de
structures en béton
vous allez avoir entre une et trois
victimes chacun sur trois ou quatre
chantiers chacun avec un temps qui est
défini OK
en moyenne il faut deux ans pour former
un chien pompier pour Mathieu et Popeye
la formation touche à sa fin ce soir
c'est l'ultime répétition avant l'examen
final
[Applaudissements]
se repérer dans l'espace ne pas perdre
de vue son chien et prendre en compte sa
fatigue olfactive autant de difficultés
qu'il faut gérer en un temps limité je
suis content du chat très très bien
travaillé il m'a fait un bon engagement
après c'est des erreurs de on a fait
plein de petites erreurs de jeunes
conducteur de moi en l'occurrence je
sais pas le reproche qu'on fait si je
fais pas assez confiance
j'insiste trop sur mes pièces c'est pour
ça que ça dure longtemps alors que lui
m'a clairement dit que
il y a personne il y a personne là
aujourd'hui l'exercice était fait pour
quand même les sortir un peu de leur
quotidien donc ils étaient pas
spécialement dans la grosse difficulté
mais c'était pour vérifier que
les actes réflexes qu'on attendent à
sapeur-pompiers étaient là et là c'était
le cas après il y a encore des petits
points perfectibles à améliorer c'était
pas parfait mais clairement c'est une
équipe qui demeure sera opérationnelle
et en qui j'aurais parfaitement
confiance
la confiance un élément indispensable
pour qu'un binôme fonctionne sur la base
aérienne 123 d'Orléans Brissy les hommes
du commando parachutiste de l'ère numéro
10 le savent parfaitement depuis
plusieurs années cette unité des forces
spéciales a placé le chien au centre des
groupes à la clé de nouvelles méthodes
de travail et du matériel dernier cri
aujourd'hui onyx un malinois de bientôt
trois ans ne tient pas en place avec
Aldo son maître il se prépare pour un
exercice revêtu d'un casque muni de
caméra
on a vraiment un visuel assez
panoramique de la vision du chien en
plus l'avantage qu'on a c'est qu'on peut
dans cette pochette mettre une petite
radio et être en liaison radio avec lui
et lui donner des commandements à
distance si nécessaire
en super combattant conique et son
maître participent au briefing ok les
gars pour une mission de reconnaissance
offensive du bâtiment il y a peut-être
présence d'un otage
le binôme travaille ensemble depuis
moins d'un an pourtant la symbiose est
totale
dans la colonne le chien reste
parfaitement silencieux et réagit au
mouvement du commando
malgré l'obscurité de la pièce l'attaque
et rapide l'ennemi est mis hors d'état
de nuire la vitesse du chien et sa
petite taille en font une scie beaucoup
moins facile à atteindre le travail de
Nyx n'est pas terminé d'autres pièces
doivent être encore passées au Crimée
sa caméra embarquée va être très
précieuse
sur la pièce savoir s'il y a pas déjà
quelqu'un et après ça peut permettre aux
chiens de
pièces on cherche d'expo
les images en haute définition prise par
la caméra du chien donne au groupe une
vision précise de la situation avec une
portée de 800 mètres l'appareil est un
atout en zone de combat
situation de doute ou lorsque il y a
suspicion de présence d'un personnel
ennemi on préfère utiliser le chien qui
sera en mesure de neutraliser un
éventuel ennemi ou alors de marquer la
présence d'un explosif et alors on
pourra adopter l'attitude adaptée pour
éviter qu'un de nos opérateurs
s'exposent de trop et soit blesser au
combat
neutraliser un ennemi détecter des
explosifs ce double emploi du chien est
une particularité du CPAS 10 il fait
gagner un temps précieux aux aviateurs
un avantage non négligeable lorsque l'on
est en opération
la journée terminée le duo peut
décompresser c'est en partie pour ces
instants de complicité caldo a toujours
voulu être maître chien
c'est le travail d'équipe c'est le
travail avec l'animal c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est pas forcément
donné à tout le monde et
moi c'était un peu un rêve de gosse donc
voilà j'ai réalisé mon rêve
ici les chiens sont complètement
intégrés à la vie quotidienne des
groupes il n'est donc pas rare de
croiser un malinois à la pause café un
moment de détente qui permet aussi aux
chiens de mémoriser les odeurs de chaque
membre des données capitales lorsqu'ils
seront en mission
et celui qui se fait chouchouter ses
tailles un beau bébé de 37 kg lauréat en
2019 du Trophée des chiens héros pour
son intervention dans la capture d'un
chef djihadiste et la localisation de
deux caches d'armes au Mali
pourtant déjà expérimenté
ice ne cesse de se perfectionner
aujourd'hui il s'exerce à la dépose de
drone terrestre avec son maître Marcus
on lui donne la caméra il apprend il
allait très très vite il nous la dépose
il revient nous on le protège avec des
boucliers et nous on aime recopie un
autre niveau de la caméra et du coup mon
chef de groupe peut anticiper
stratégiquement on va aller à droite on
va aller à gauche attention il y a
peut-être quelqu'un alors
grâce à ce matériel transporté par ice
le groupe spécialisé dans le contrôle
terrorisme et la libération d'otages est
moins exposée pour le chien c'est un
travail qu'il faut répéter encore et
encore afin d'être toujours plus
efficace sur le terrain même chose pour
son harnais il est le fruit d'un retour
d'expérience des premières missions en
Afghanistan les opérateurs peuvent y
accrocher des lampes des grenades ou des
garons
utile pour eux comme pour le chien
le fait avec le chien c'est en
permanence avec les opérateurs en fait
nous tout le monde peut aller peut se
servir sur Ace que le toucher il y a
jamais de on demande son chien il va pas
être dangereux il va pas attaquer
quelqu'un en fait c'est extrêmement bien
équilibré il est vraiment intégré à 100%
avec avec l'équipe
très bien protégé même si cela le
dérange parfois
donc là on va lui mettre les petits
chaussons pour protéger tout ce qui est
coussinet en fait donc
à 200 donc c'est pour tout ce qui est
travaillant en zone
rocheuses très abrasive des bris en
bâtiment
c'est compliqué après on est pour le
chien alors au début c'est assez rigolo
ça ressemble un peu à un cheval ou une
espèce de girafe qui apprend à marcher
doucement allez même là il sait ce qu'il
attend donc il est pas très content
ces chaussons ne sont pas des gadgets
ils ont fait leurs preuves au Mali dans
la vallée de lame détaille connue pour
ses pierres noires coupantes
habituer l'animal à les porter est
essentielle c'est aussi le cas pour son
masque utilisez cette fois via sa vision
infrarouge
avec son redoutable savoir-faire à il se
trouvera rapidement la charge explosive
cachée
montre-moi mets ton ex
supérieur du casier et là en fait il va
plus bouger maintenant il va nous
attendre il attend en fait qu'on le
rappelle quand le faire revenir
travailler pour le protéger lui parce
que ça reste quand même une dans la
réalité ce serait une matière explosive
améliorer les technologies et les
techniques est un lait motif quotidien
chez les maîtres chiens du CPAS
en novembre 2020 ils ont réalisé une
première mondiale faire sauter sous
oxygène au Laos avec son maître Pablo un
exploit rendu possible grâce au projet
arcane imaginé par Travis un lieutenant
opérationnel lorsqu'il était en
formation ce dernier étant déployé en
opération ses compagnons d'aventure nous
racontent
moi je suis enseignant chercheur à
l'école de l'air et on a échangé autour
de son sujet de mémoire de fin d'études
oui s'interrogeait sur la possibilité de
pouvoir emmener un chien dans toutes les
possibilités de mise en place au niveau
du CPA 10 dont l'exigeant saut
opérationnel à très grande hauteur
on a fait appel au vétérinaire Thierry
pour pouvoir nous amener sa connaissance
aussi sur le chien toute la physiologie
du chien on a discuté on a dit bon ça
n'existe nulle part on se lance on est
allé chercher de soutien auprès de
l'agence innovation des défenses qui
nous a soutenu financièrement et puis on
s'est lancé donc dès 2017 pour arriver à
une version validée 2021
la première question c'était nécessaire
de mettre le chien sous oxygène et en
fait la réponse elle est loin d'être
aussi simple puisque l'oxygène n'est pas
forcément quelque chose de bénéfique en
particulier pour le chien et puis
deuxième contrainte c'est que il faut
lui faire respirer de l'oxygène mais en
total étanchéité pour qu'il ait un
pourcentage d'oxygène qui se rapproche
de 100 % et ça c'est pareil mais en fait
la conformation du chien elle est pas du
tout comme la nôtre une année entière et
une dizaine de modèles ont été
nécessaires pour valider la forme
définitive du masque tout cela en
préservant l'intégrité physique de
l'équipier à quatre pattes
et forcément au centre de toutes les
discussions et de tout ce qu'on fait
nous bien évidemment mais c'est pour ça
qu'en fait le réflexe de tous les
maîtres chiens je dirais quand ils
volent sans parler d'innovation mais
quand ils veulent mettre en place un
nouveau matériel en règle générale on
est très vite associé nous vétérinaire
et si le j'avais pas bien ou quoi ça
pourrait pas matcher quand on dit tout
ça en fait ça fait partie du package on
peut dire ça comme ça ou si le chien est
bien dans sa tête bien dans son corps
etc il peut donner que des bons
résultats au même titre que l'homme quoi
et pour sauter à très grande auteur
depuis la soute d'un transat que l'on
soit un chien ou un humain il faut être
bien préparé
exceptionnellement le duo à l'écran joue
pour nous les mannequins entre le
parachute la gaine le casque ou encore
le masque le chuteur va porter pas moins
de 130 kg sur lui le chien a une fois
que il sera arrivé au sol avec son
maître le maître va le déséquiper le
sorteur de son harnais et le GR va
pouvoir travailler on va dire
normalement même après un saut de très
grande auteur et c'est ça qui fait un
peu la différence pour des chiens comme
les notes c'est qu'ils arrivent à faire
un travail on va dire classique entre
guillemets en ayant fait une dérive sous
voile très loin de toi
le rapport cette innovation
exceptionnelle a remporté au mois de
juin le premier prix du Commandement des
Opérations Spéciales à l'occasion du
Salon des forces spéciales à sous en
Gironde
et le système arcane ça permet
aujourd'hui de pouvoir déployer et
mettre à terre les équipes des forces
spéciales partout dans le monde
n'importe quel point du globe tout le
temps n'importe où n'importe quand le
dispositif devrait être bientôt présenté
aux autres armées en attendant les
aviateurs d'Orléans travaillent déjà sur
de nouveaux projets
si au fil du temps le rôle des chiens et
leur statut a évolué au sein des armées
leur engagement leur loyauté et leur
abnégation n'ont jamais fait défaut
les témoignages de reconnaissance
rappellent toute la pertinence de
l'emploi du chien dans les opérations
aucun doute leur avenir est assuré aux
côtés des militaires
[Musique]